so and then what happened with you were
friends with Abba and preach for a while
or Abba like no I wasn't friends with
them okay they would show up on a
destiny panel where I'd be trolling
Stardust and I guess his feelings got
hurt and then he starts just screaming
at me Circle you'll never be you'll
never be that I'll do a twenty thousand
dollar bet that you won't have a hundred
thousand Subs this year because on
YouTube because you're lazy you're this
and I I offered a different bet that's
more realistic for him I'm like you're
about this is easy
and now it's like he's gonna find the
better sort of probably but uh basically
he's blue pill so Abba hates Christians
on the low I mean this guy got his uh
ass licked by his woman woman would
preach or whatever and he said it he
said it's not gay and he knows my
position on it so he immediately hates
me because I'm gonna call it gay
I don't know yeah
and I used to make fun of Myron and
fresh all the time not a fan like I
roasted everyone right everyone could
get it but and two thousand people on my
track were on Abbas and preacher's side
red pill guys on their side and like
don't you see what's happening here like
these are the bad guys
so I defended them even when I didn't
know them like a year ago there's a clip
on YouTube
but yeah I always I hate Bluefield
people like they always eventually snake
you know I actually think Destiny's the
least snake from the blue pill crowd you
know he's like the most watered down if
you have a relationship with them well I
don't know
preach will call you a rapist so if they
call Martin a rapist imagine what they
do to me yeah yeah well even um freaking
that I used to like think that like Adam
preacher were right because I thought
Myron looked like insane in that one
video like when he was like we are
better like like I really thought it was
insane like just watching like clips and
everything
um but it wasn't until they started
doing it to me that I realized what they
do where they'll like they'll take a
clip like there's this podcast I was
like joking about this is before I
actually thought women shouldn't vote so
it's funny because now I actually do
think that but back then I didn't I
swear like you lost like you yeah yeah I
was I was just joking around about it
and they clipped it like I really
thought that we should not vote but you
know I guess maybe they just
foreshadowed it because then I changed
my mind on that later you know you get
more red and then there was like I
forgot what the next one was but they
would like always clip out all contacts
um and I just realized like what the
real like all of the reaction channels
do that and then when you point them
like you point to them and you say
you're not providing contacts then
they'll say oh that's a cop-out but I'm
like no it's actually not
um but yeah that was how I started to
like flip I don't know my opinion on it
because I just started to see what they
were doing when they started doing it to
me
yeah I mean there's a way to roast
channels and be reacting a React channel
with with being charitable at the same
time and those guys are not it dude like
remember they're a lot more red than you
think buying clothes doors but they know
how to play to the audience right they
want everyone to be watching their video
not just like a red side or a blue side
they're businessmen
but it's slimy business you know it's
atheist business right they don't have
like malls yeah I mean Apple even said
in one of the videos that he made it
like
um he made it like a race thing like
when I I sent him a video of me telling
a girl that a 200k ring is delusional
and he's like oh this white girl he's he
was like he was like this white girl's
like clowning black women like what does
that have to do with race like it's it's
a 200k engagement ring that's insane and
I was really nice about it in the video
like if you actually watch the video
it's actually quite private yeah no no
it's funny that the audience just goes
with whatever they're saying even if
they don't understand it like that has
nothing to do with race or like for me
it's funny the monkey joke isn't as
funny as my caveman joke because you
look uh preach looks like a man like
Neanderthal and I made a spirit Trucking
joke
they changed it to oh it's a race joke
as like uh and I made an evolution joke
like from Neanderthal human and they're
like he's saying this black man is a
monkey
and I'm like you know what's funny I
don't care if you say that bro actually
now that you say that I will say it
but
that is not my joke and but I guess it
looks bad because I'm laughing at Myron
going
it's a giant police police officer on
live going oh
being racist and [__] or racist you know
making racial comedy
and to me that's just funny
and I never once even did that joke or
like the uh I know they're convinced her
because the type to say hard R it's
never been a clip of me saying hard
artar ever or anyone who's ever heard me
say it because like I don't like the
gamer
uh comedy but when Myron does it ex
police officer who's black it looks
[__] ridiculous obviously I'm gonna
laugh but man they're UPS I know they
don't think we're racist but they know
what they're doing you know
well unfortunate yeah and even they gave
like um Myron like they're on me so hard
about saying I would accept like a guy
that cheats and they always misquote
what I say I don't I say if you're
married you got kids like I think you
should try to work it out and I looked
at studies behind like when they
interviewed cheaters and let's just say
the cheaters are lying right 85 percent
of cheaters it's a one-time thing
and let's say the cheaters live whoa is
that true yeah yeah yeah so it's it's
it's roughly it's breaking imagine
destroying the family unit for a
one-time thing wow thank you thank you
and let's say let's double it let's see
let's see let's say that I mean it's
self-reported right but let's say the
cheaters are big Liars Circa let's just
say they're the baby come on who's gonna
tell the truth double it okay that's
still the majority it's a one time I
mean how often are men getting thrown at
them let's just be honest for the
average like guy you know so it's like
in my head you know I I don't want to be
cheated on I wish not to be you know but
they'll frame it like I want to be
cheated on I'm like I do not but when
you when you see how much more
anti-social men are than women
women shouldn't really worry about men
cheating they should worry about being
like very [__] and annoying at home
because when men have girlfriends
everyone agrees that we just play
Playstation and go to work we stay home
very loyal if the environment's Cozy no
man goes to the club when they have a
girlfriend they hate we hate clubs when
we have girlfriends all right right
women don't get it the problem is the
environment is so horrible that the man
thinks yeah I'm not gonna make it with
this [__] [__] she's so [__] I
need to look for someone else and that's
the problem and you know what's funny is
men don't throw away marriages for some
[__] hoe Who's hotter than their wife
because they've invested Bond time
energy all this stuff into the wife
so she the woman's usually safe it's the
woman who will upgrade the woman will
upgrade that's in her DNA well and and
you see it like they don't believe in
marriage like and it's really offensive
to people that believe in me like I I
think I had a debate with um destiny
where I was saying like that you
shouldn't get divorced over chores and
he's like oh what are you acting like a
child right now and I'm like no because
I believe in the sanctity of marriage
and that's the way they'll frame it it's
like they they've completely lost what
marriage is supposed to be and it's
actually it's quite offensive to like
people that are and I'm not even a
die-hard like super super Catholic
person but like I it's kind of offensive
when it's like you're taking a vow with
God and you're getting divorced over a
one-time cheating chores over like
little things that could be little if
you let it be little
yeah it's almost like he watched porn
but you know that's almost the same
thing of what he did is it wasn't that
deep but you know like so I remember my
cousin calling me a fake red pill
because like on camera I could do a lot
of jokes like this but my girlfriend I
would never let her bring uh uh clean my
room or bring me water or like do chores
for me because I can't see a human
slaving away from me I don't know why I
can't I can't see my mom do it for me I
was like stop doing this stop doing me
favors I don't like when humans do that
I feel really cringe when I'm a fresher
fit and the girls bring me stuff because
I just feel like
I don't know I just can't do that you
know and I gotta overcome that and say
[__] do some [__] house work but
really I I want
yeah I've never been that kind of guy
that's a you know I'm red building
everywhere every place but I don't want
her to cook food I want to order food
all I wanted to do is sit in front of a
[__] mirror and be pretty and stay
around me quiet right and it's like
the weird thing is if you're not in the
authority position where you're like
cleaning the house they leave you like
think of it if I got into a woman's car
and I sat in the passenger seat kicked
my feet up and said babe where are you
taking me
dude that is the biggest turn off to a
woman
so it's like we men don't actually real
like we'd love to kick our feet up you
take initiative and drive her to the
restaurant and plan it and all that
because that's what arouses her to you
know keep her around but it's like a lot
of people think men want to be over a
woman no no they have to or they lose
her we'd love to say I'm not working
[__] this [__] you work we'd love to
[__] kick it for a couple months but
we love to work too so we'll go back to
that but it's like I don't teach men to
be the authority in the relationship
because it's like fetish like red pill
guys yeah she's doing what I want no
it's because she's gonna leave you if
you don't right even I think there's a
president who said his game was he makes
his woman doing favors all the time and
she psychically thinks if I'm doing
favors he must be my boyfriend was it
like Edison or someone I forgot what it
was like this quote but it turned out to
be true
the more she's investing in you the more
she'll stick around which is so weird
it's like a woman's like a golden
retriever you know put the [__] to work
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible